is
[Music]
my son is absolutely horrendous they
think this is information and they don't
know might they ever get defend them
back on my lap this is why I'm sitting
in a hotel room on my own with none of
my family cry my eyesight for
smile that I do not want this is not
what we agreed I I paid for 20 ear
crimes you've got me Bridges who would
be happy with this
[Music]
so here I am and then at this channel I
get the work corrected of what happened
in Turkey because I'm absolutely Agony
and I have to stop for four nights I
knew that I got a bad job but it's gonna
cost me 18 000 pounds maybe more to get
my fixed the damage that they have done
us so bad the teeth aren't even in right
it's just brutal they've
absolutely ripped my life and I am not
even joking the billion Iron Man is
unbearable
foreign
[Music]
is really heartbreaking and I saw this
video that was going really viral so I
reached out to her and asked if there's
anything I can do you know I expect you
on the phone Etc and I offered her to
come into the clinic and had a look and
we basically found out that she had
multiple infections she had broken teeth
she had teeth that were all joins
together so essentially they drilled
down every tooth in her mouth but made
them all kind of one segment so she
couldn't get a toothbrush in their floss
no incidental brushes nothing so the
gums were profusely infected and
bleeding and we basically had to come up
with a plan unfortunately though she
flew back and then after a couple of
weeks she got an infection so bad that
it ended up spreading to the side of her
neck it affected her breathing she ended
up in hospital she ended up on a drip
and she actually said it was one of the
most difficult times of her life all
right oh
is like
as far as I opened my eyes
so I'm gonna have to have my breathing
suits put up my nose while I'm awake
because they can help me to sleep until
I know what it perceives or safely am I
wrong this is face pattern
so I was a surgery there for a few hours
all I say is see for all the people who
maybe want your dancing shoes on
anywhere outside the UK look at this
do you still want to go and get that
treatment though
do you know complications
can well arrived I was staying in touch
with her constantly but it wasn't until
she was out of hospital and the swelling
has subsided to a point that she could
then function that she was able to fly
back to the clinic and we could take all
of that work off as a starting point
I just want to see sort of in terms of
pain first of all
um kind of what you're feeling and
experiencing so that taste empathetic
it's good in just to keep it you know
clean so the subtle infection until I
was able to come so as a team the first
thing that we have to do we had to
create something called lab-made shell
Temporaries so my technician has to
create little temporary teeth to go on
top of the little stumps on her teeth
once the old work was removed the old
work took about 12 hours to remove so
about six hours from the top then Amanda
had a lunch break and then had six hours
of removal as well on the bottom
so I'm just sitting at home here
chilling with a nice solid
[Music]
I can't start running my tongue although
because they actually disability on my
my own tasted before I went to Turkey
none of her teeth are going to be her
actual teeth anymore because everything
that she's had done is irreversible so
we are going to be providing new crowns
for her which means that we've got new
ceramic work going on top but of course
the new teeth are going to be separated
they're not going to be all joined
together actually before they're going
to be Contour to the gun properly the
bite is going to be proper all of these
things means that she can function
properly the forecast for the whole
package in Amanda's case is between 60
to 70 000 pounds unfortunately she
didn't know what was going to happen she
literally just dreams of having the
perfect smile and you know most people
do they're not told of all the
complications she would have never done
it otherwise
[Music]
even if you're thinking about being on
the board because you perceive it to be
more good affordable get a consultation
at least in the UK so at least just pay
to that consultation where you can get
the options because the options will be
presented to you it might be just do
whitening do braces whitening and
bonding do braces and veneers but if you
go for the consultation you're going to
be given all the different options
whether you go for them or not you know
that your only option isn't just
with anything good can come off this
whole ordeal is that other people have
been able to see the story and you know
if they still insist and go on they're
going to go to clinics who are verified
to be very good you know they're not
just going to go to this here dodgy
dentists like one I clearly went to you
know but yeah here's the new beginnings
[Music]
that's like the burnt skin the graphic
skin and then
this is where they connect the skin
together that scar
and for the other side
this is actually my real skin
and they're actually the kind of matches
the donor skin pretty good